All right, cool. We're rolling. Dude, Joel, I have a little surprise for you at the beginning
of this episode that I wasn't going to tell you about. I'm super excited because I just
went onto our Spotify, and there are 56 five-star reviews on Spotify.
Are you serious?
Yeah, man. I was super surprised when I went in there. You guys really came through for
us on those Spotify reviews, so thank you so much for that. And on top of that, we have
10 five-star reviews on Apple Podcasts, and five of them are, like, or four of them
are actual, like, text reviews. So I want to just give a shout-out right now to
Defparam, MaxPower99, 1911Rocky, and JosefFuego555 for dropping some awesome
reviews for us on Apple Podcasts. We really appreciate that, and that really
keeps us hyped to keep producing content.
Dude, that's so awesome. Yeah, thanks a lot to everybody who's been taking the time
to listen. We've been getting a ton of good feedback on Twitter. Everybody says
that they're really enjoying listening to the content. So we're just glad to be, you
know, pushing this out, and hope you keep enjoying it.
It's so exciting, right, man? People have been tweeting and stuff like that, and
every time I just get, like, hyped to go do some research for the next episode and
stuff. So yeah, definitely appreciate that. But yeah, okay, so I guess let's just dive
right in today. Actually, you know what? So we're going to talk
today about the Portswigger top 10 web hacking techniques of 2022, which was pretty much the
biggest piece of content that was released over the past couple weeks, sort of outlining
what the top web hacking techniques of 2022 were, and kind of do a little bit of a -- I
don't know if we can do a deep dive, because it's -- there's 10 of them, and we've only
got an hour here. But we're just going to try to skate over each one of those, give some
comments on them, talk about the various techniques. But before that, the drama, Joel, the drama.
Because we shouted out TruffleSec on our podcast a couple weeks ago, and shit hit the fan. So tell me a little bit about that.
Yeah, so you may have seen there was some drama on Twitter and whatnot, but basically, I believe the TLDR is that Truffle Security with the new
XSS hunter, basically. They were logging statistics about, you know, callbacks and all that kind of stuff.
Security people don't like that shit, man. They really don't.
And yeah, they tweeted out like a summary that was essentially, here's all the callbacks that we've had, you know, successful exploits, all that kind of stuff.
And people were pretty pissed because they were like, hang on a second. You're looking at our stats. You're looking at our callbacks.
You could just be taking our bugs. You could just be seeing these zero days that are being exploited.
So I have seen some people mention that you should self-host your own instance of XSS hunter, which is definitely a viable option if you have a server or you want to just spin up a little instance.
And I've even seen some programs go as far as to say that they won't accept reports that are using an externally hosted XSS hunter.
So you have to use your own.
Yeah, I saw that too. It was right surrounding this drama too, I think, right? Like one of the biggest programs out there kind of send out a message on HackerOne and said like, hey,
if you use a non self-hosted XSS hunter instance, then no bounty for you.
Yeah, yeah. And that's like, I think it's pretty rare when I see a program react to that quickly and that aggressively, I guess, which is pretty surprising, but I think it's generally a good move.
And I think that Truffle security has also sort of stepped back and said, you know, this wasn't really intentional.
We were just trying to celebrate the use of the product.
We're not trying to steal your bugs or anything, but I think the point remains that, you know, this is something you should probably just think about and keep an eye on if you're using externally hosted tools.
Just remember that those people can have logs of anything you're putting in there, right? So if you're putting in a zero day or some bug that hasn't been reported or released, you never know who's going to see that.
You never know who has access to those logs. So just be cautious, think before you paste all that kind of stuff.
Yeah, man, I don't know. Maybe it's a hot take and I am notoriously not privacy conscious, you know, like I've got Google Homes all over my house and, you know, all sorts of stuff.
You know, all sorts of stuff like that, but don't don't use that against me, guys. Maybe I shouldn't publicly admit that on the podcast, but I don't know, man.
I don't think it's that big of a deal. I mean, clearly it was just a statistic. It's not like they're in here like saying, hey, you know, run reader, congrats on your blind access.
That would be creepy. That would be creepy. But in this case, it's just, it's just statistics. And, you know, obviously it's not a great idea anyway, because vulnerabilities there, you know, they definitely
should be tried to kept private between the bug bounty hunter and the, you know, company you're reporting it to. And so there's definitely some, some, I definitely understand from the program side of them saying something like, hey, we don't want to see this on our program.
But I think the backlash on Twitter was a little bit, a little bit overdone, especially considering the fact that Truffle security is providing a free service to us and actually went in and enhanced the product and then was just kind of celebrating their, their dub on like, oh, you know, we got cool Git issues, cloud credentials and cores popping up.
So I don't know. Maybe that's a hot take.
Yeah, no, I think I'm with you on that. It's like, it's kind of tricky because on one hand, we want to be like very like security positive. And on the other hand, like they have a product, they need to like promote it. Right.
I don't think that Truffle security is doing what people are sort of like alluding to, which is that they're going into the logs, they're looking at the things, your callbacks, and then they're taking your bugs and like doing who knows what with them.
I would be very surprised, right? If you think about it from like a business perspective, it's not great optics if that's what you're doing.
Yeah.
If that were to get out in any way, which since people are already kind of like saying that that could be a thing, you know, it would be a pretty dumb idea.
And they're a security company, right? Like I feel like they have some ethics already.
Like they kind of know. And in their statement, they sort of address that.
So I think it is a little bit of an aggressive move from the community, just being like, you know, screwed, Truffle security, host your own and all that kind of stuff.
But, you know, security people are going to be security people.
They are. They are.
We're all getting different paranoid.
Yeah. And, you know, the privacy piece, I don't know.
I have definitely been called out a couple of times about not being conscious about that.
But I also feel like that almost, it almost feels to me like delusions of grandeur, right?
Like if I were like, if I were like, you know, I don't know, like head of the CIA or something like that and people had a reason to like want to get in my Google home and just hear like the stupid conversations I have with my wife or like, you know, weird shit like that, then then I would be a little bit more security conscious.
But like at the end of the day, I'm a podcast host.
I'm a solo entrepreneur, bug bounty hunter.
Like, you know, who's really going to go through all the trouble and use a Google home exploit to, you know, pop me.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
That's just how it is.
I don't know if you said that like your threat model should be your threat model.
Yeah.
It doesn't have to be like a universal threat model.
Like you sort of should just look at your life, look at your context and decide how secure you need to be.
Yeah.
So like if you're worried that somebody is going to be dropping a zero day on you, is that a valid concern?
Maybe like maybe some Russian state like actor is going to drop a zero day on you.
I don't know, man.
I have I have heard some pretty some pretty like crazy shit, though, about like foreign states and vulnerability researchers.
So, you know, I'll definitely you know, my threat model definitely includes being careful around specific foreign countries.
But yeah.
So making me go back and forth on this.
I know.
Well, we'll we'll we'll talk about it off off the air.
But yeah, there's definitely some weird stuff that's happened.
But yeah.
OK.
So truffle truffle security.
That's our take.
Take it or leave it.
Your threat model should be your own risk.
If you're really concerned, host it yourself.
That's pretty much it.
Or or or and you didn't get this advice here.
Use it.
And then when you get the call back, go host your own and then do it again and get the call back again and report that.
You know, didn't hear it here.
You know, I don't know who that was that just took over the mic, but all right.
No, no, no.
OK, so the next thing that I wanted to talk about real quick before we hop into the port swigger top 10 was, well, two things real quick to just little news blurbs.
Fuff released Fuff 2.0 and it's got some real nice new features surrounding being able to track back which requests caused a certain functionality and then also being able to extract data out of your Fuff, which with, you know, your Fuff searches or your Fuff brute forces, which I think is a huge feature.
I use that in intruder all the time, you know, they'll like match and extract sort of feature in intruder.
So definitely love to see that.
As always, Juhui, Juhui knocks it out of the park.
Juhui, I don't know.
I'm sorry, bro.
But you knock it out of the park with Fuff.
So thank you for that awesome community contribution and just wanted to shout it out.
And then also Kaido released a super nice HTML preview feature, which I use all the time in Burp Sweep and was stinging a little bit.
It took a little getting used to to not have that in Kaido and now I can just have it in Kaido.
So another great reason to check Kaido out.
Yeah, yeah, that's awesome.
And when we were talking about FFUF, I was just thinking about a conversation I had with Jay Haddix not long ago about the scanner brute force or dirt search or whatever that he uses.
And he uses one called Ferox Buster, which I had never heard of.
Yeah, I think I did hear him mention this.
Yeah, it's a really cool tool.
It's written in Rust, super fast.
And he actually prefers it over FFUF, I believe.
Wow.
Mainly just because it does like it has some nice features like you can interrupt it.
You can modify the search as it's going in real time.
You can sort of interact with those with those results that it's already found.
And it's written Rust.
I think FFUF is Go, right?
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
So probably a little bit faster, but it's really it's really cool.
You can see other other nice tools in this space.
I use both kind of depending on use case, but I've definitely been leaning a little bit towards Ferox Buster just for the different use cases and to try out that new tool.
So definitely check them both out.
But the new version of FFUF V2 is like packed full of awesome features like you were talking about.
So if you haven't updated your FFUF in a while, update it and give it a run and check it out.
The content discovery wars continue.
I feel like every couple of years I'm switching, you know, from product to product, just chasing the extra, you know, little bit of efficiency or the nice new features.
So always, always appreciate the scan with Python.
Oh, my gosh, dude.
I still have code running on my server that scans with Python because, you know, sometimes you just need to be you need slow and steady, you know.
Slow and steady wins the race.
That's exactly right.
All right, cool.
Well, let's with that, let's let's go ahead and hop into the Portsweger top 10 web hacking techniques.
Drum roll.
I don't know if you can hear that, but I'm drum rolling.
Dude, I get so excited when I see this every year because these techniques are such fire.
And it actually took quite a few hours to read through all of these in prep for this podcast because they're so good and so in-depth.
And a lot of them are really, really complex.
So I've still got a couple in here that I don't fully understand.
So hopefully we can kind of talk that through or maybe someone in the one of our listeners can pop in and explain it to me.
Yeah, 100 percent.
A lot of these, I was surprised I hadn't even heard about them.
And I was reading through them and they're all like fantastic write-ups.
It kind of varies across the space, the quality of write-ups that you can see.
But these were all very top tier, well-written, well-documented, well-explained.
They have diagrams and pictures and, yeah, definitely very well-written write-ups.
So I would encourage anybody who's curious about more of these, we'll link it in the description below.
But we'll put the top 10 list from Portsweger.
We'll put the article there and you can look through them all.
And there's also, they included the list of nominees.
That's always a good read.
Even more, there's like an infinite list of like research that you can read through there.
But these, I think I honestly prefer it to the OWASP top 10.
OWASP is just a little too generic for me.
I really appreciate the level of specificity that each of these goes into where it's more like a specific bug.
And it talks about sort of the methodology and stuff behind it.
Yeah, no, that makes sense.
I, you know, the OWASP top 10, I think, definitely has its spot.
But this is sort of in a different category for me personally.
Because, yeah, these are actual, you know, specific techniques and hands-on, you know, vulnerabilities, which has a different ring to it.
And also, I just, I love the fact that this, I just wanted to shout out File Descriptor on here.
He's on the expert panel of researchers that kind of helps put together this.
I haven't seen much from him in the past couple of years since before, before COVID.
But I love that guy.
And he does a great job with, and the rest of this panel is obviously amazing too.
So thank you for the excellent work, people over at Portsweger and people on the panel for this top 10 web hacking techniques document.
You can always be almost, like, 100% certain that there's some really crazy cool research going on behind the scenes when File Descriptor is being quiet.
Oh, I know.
Yeah, yeah.
I can't wait to see what he comes up with, man.
I still, he's still, like, my go-to.
Like, if I have some weird, dude, your cat is on top of your printer.
Trying to break my printer.
Yeah, man, he's still my go-to whenever I have, like, some crazy, like, hey, is this possible in any, you know, edge browser versions?
Or, like, weird stuff like that.
He's the one.
So, all right, cool.
Let's check out number 10 on the list.
This one goes to none other than Mr. Curry, Sam himself, Mr. Zazzle, as he's known in the live hacking circuit.
This is a universal XSS on Netlify.
And actually, dude, I'm a little salty about this one.
I told this to Sam, too, because he told me about this when he was, before he released it.
And I was like, dude, I freaking knew there was bugs in that, in those endpoints.
Like, I just didn't, that's just one of these ones that I, like, had it on my list of sketchy stuff.
And then I actually just never went down the hole.
And then, you know, some crazy bugs pop up later.
So, props to Sam for doing that.
That's the worst feeling when you're, like, it's, like, it's tingling.
You're, like, hacker, like, SpideySense.
And you're, like, I should put this on my list.
Maybe I'll check it out later.
Six months later, you're dealing with too many other things.
And then, boom, out of nowhere, blog post.
And you're, like, ah, I knew it.
Yep, I know it, man.
That FOMO.
So, all right, I'll take, let's do it this way.
I'll talk about, there's three bugs in this one.
I'll talk about one, you talk about two, and then we'll join and talk about three or whatever.
So, the first bug on this little list here is an open redirect.
And it's pretty, fairly straightforward.
But one of the things I do want to highlight here is that it utilizes something that I think people should be aware of in these sort of situations is the way that browsers redirect when you give backslashes and, like, for example, you don't have to have HTTPS in the beginning of your location header to get an open redirect.
You can do it with slash slash.
You can do it with some combination of slashes and backslashes.
So, when you're looking, trying to break a regex for open redirection or something of the like, then definitely, you know, kind of play around with all these different values.
And sometimes you can even get chains where, you know, you give it one thing and then it redirects to something else.
And then when it normalizes the thing that you told it to redirect to, that causes a redirect.
So, brilliant work here by Sam as well.
And I think Sam was also one of the people that kind of helped foster this behavior in me as well, just kind of seeing Sam's bug at live hacking event and just from hacking together.
So, yeah, really, really good stuff here.
And I love how he also mentions that a lot of these sites are also using OAuth.
And, you know, later in the top 10 list, we'll talk about OAuth and how you can use open redirects to try to do stuff with OAuth.
So, definitely not shying away from dropping an open redirects the other day because it can definitely be used in chains for much more impact.
Yeah, I feel open redirects are one of those things that, like in the beginning, like it's one of the first things that you think is like, oh, this is a cool bug.
But the more you push into it, the more you're like, this isn't like quite, this isn't quite severe enough to be like something that just report on itself.
But then just like one step further is you just get a little more experience.
You realize like it's a perfect like chain mechanism.
And if you find one, just like write it down, keep track of it, give it to like work with somebody else on it because almost certainly there's a really good use case where we can escalate that impact.
Yeah.
You rarely have to report them on, you know, alone.
You can almost always escalate them and use them in some other parts of chains.
Yeah.
So, the second thing that Sam and I don't know if Sam was working alone on this or if they were working with other people.
But the second thing that they found was both an SSRF and an XSS.
So, essentially, there was this path that you could get within the Netlify IPX library.
And you do slash, I think, underscore IPX and then W underscore 200.
I think that's for basically like a thumbnail type.
You give it a resolution or whatever.
And then you would, in the path, you would URL encode an HTTP URL and it would just fetch it.
And it would check for it to be an SVG and then it would just render it.
So, if your SVG had an XSS payload in it because SVG is vector-based, so you can put elements in it and you can run XSS through it.
So, it would SSRF out to your server, assuming, I think there was actually a host check somewhere.
Yeah, it says in here that there's some whitelist and he was a little bit frustrated that it wasn't a totally universal exploit.
Which, dude, as a piece of software, you don't want to go up against a frustrated Sam Curry, man.
Yeah, but this is one of those use cases that we were talking about, right?
Open redirects is a perfect example.
If there's some sort of host, if there's a host whitelist, allow list, and you need to get around that, find an open redirect within that host and then use it to get to your own host.
Yeah, no, absolutely.
And so, for the third one, where he does fully, you know, get arbitrary universal XSS on any of these instances, any of these Netlify instances, is when he gets into the, you know, white box source code review.
Which is really, I think this is a technique that I've been working on with my mentees a little bit more lately, and they've been really eating up.
Is this getting into the code, really starting to, you know, read through trace, trace data inputs, and it would have been very hard to find this otherwise, I think.
But what he does here is he goes through and he finds in the, in the source code for Netlify IPX, he finds the exported protocol header is being parsed and integrated into these requests.
And, you know, it's, it's easy to think, okay, well, that's just, would just be for protocols.
But after reading the code, he actually finds that you can just stick a whole URL in there as the protocol and, and then just truncate the rest of the request using a question mark at the end.
Or I'm sure you could use a hashtag as well, making it a part of the URL fragment.
And then the end, that's the thing that, that gives him the full SSRF.
And I want to point out here, one of the things that Sam does really well, which is Sam understands the threat model here, right?
You know, he normally if he's got an SSRF zero day, he'd be talking about the SSRF, not the XSS, but these are static websites.
And so at the end of the day, there's not a lot of impact to the SSRF.
And there is literally the most impact you can possibly have on these static websites is XSS.
And so he does, he does a really good job here of highlighting that actually this results in cross-site scripting, which is the primary impact in these sort of scenarios.
So shout out to Sam for, for that and for not getting distracted by the cool, shiny bug type name of SSRF and actually following the threat model for the websites.
Yeah. And I think another great thing to call out here is that this is Next.js, right?
So Next.js is used very, very frequently within Web3 websites where you're dealing with NFTs, minting and wallets and approvals.
And there's a lot of, there's a lot of risk at hand.
And so being able to have arbitrary like XSS on any of those websites is huge because most of the time these websites are designed very, very specifically to only let you mint a certain thing or sign a certain message or something like that with your wallet.
And if you can make the user do something else completely unexpected, you could literally empty their wallet.
You could steal all of their money.
Oh my gosh. So impactful.
There's a huge amount of risk and the fact that it's universal and it's such a widely used library.
It's just an awesome finding.
Yeah. Way to go, Sam et al. on that one.
Jumping to number nine on the list, we've got, let's see, who is this by?
It says Medi in the list, but I'm not actually familiar with this hacker, so I'm going to have to check them out.
But I am familiar with and absolutely love client-side patch reversals.
And it's just such a little scrappy bug that you're like, really, are you trying to make something out of a client-side patch reversal?
But, dude, it really has some crazy impact sometime.
And I always pay attention to these because anytime you're taking user input and you're integrating it into requests, you know, there's potential, there's risk there.
And I think even as we see more and more of same-site strict adoption happening, and I talked about this in other podcasts, but I'll say it again.
As we see same-site strict, or even same-site lax, but particularly same-site strict, getting adopted by more and more websites in the future, this is going to be the new C-Surf.
It's trying to figure out how to make these requests, trying to abuse the requests that websites are making on their own from the same origin, and then using that for your benefit.
And I think this hacker here does a really good job of doing this in this write-up.
Yeah, 100%.
And we've talked about this in previous episodes, because I think actually one of the bugs that we talked about was a client-side.
Yeah, it had some pieces of it.
Yeah.
Yeah, and so very similar concept.
Obviously, it's case-by-case, but this is another one of those great examples where chaining bugs together, open redirects, and sort of thinking about the context of the application and building that impact scenario around the application, just like a great use case.
So, essentially, the bug is that there was a parameter that you could provide in the URL, and it would cause the client to load a CSS with that parameter in the URL.
And so they were able to chain this with an open redirect that they had found and a path traversal, so the dot, dot, slash, dot, dot, slash, dot, slash, and then hit their open redirect path and open redirect it to an attacker-controlled resource that is a CSS file.
And then you use CSS exfiltration, which is something that we've also briefly touched on.
Freaking love that, man.
Yeah, at some point, we should maybe give a full in-depth discussion about it.
Dude, I've got such a – I'm sorry to steal it, but I've just got such a crazy bug, such a crazy CSS injection bug that I've got to talk about on this stream.
So, that's coming.
I'm going to tease you all right now.
It's so good.
But, yeah, okay, we'll talk about that later.
Continue.
Sorry.
Yeah, no, and I mean, I wanted you to talk about that because we had mentioned it like – this is the Singapore bug, right?
No, this is actually – so that – so this is actually my bug, and I know the Singapore bug was – well, actually, I won't say whose bug it was, but really awesome hacker.
But, dude, actually, I'm not sure you've even seen this one because you weren't in – actually, I can't say what it is either because that also gives it away.
But I don't know that you saw this one because you weren't in person at this event.
I think you were remote, so I'm not sure you tuned into the show and tell.
It's probably the bug that I'm most proud of, like, as far as, like, I just put a crap ton of time in here, and it just uses all these different, like, scrappy edge techniques.
And in the end, it comes together so beautifully.
So, anyway, okay, I'll talk about it at a different time.
You'll get to see it.
You got me hyped to hear about that at the end.
Okay.
So, yeah, like Joel said, taking a parameter, so, you know, you redirect the victim to a specific URL with an attacker-controlled parameter,
and that parameter gets injected into a CSS file, which is dynamically loaded based off of that input.
You use the input to do a path traversal, hit an open redirect that you found, and that redirects to the attacker-controlled CSS file.
And when the attacker's CSS code is loaded on the website, you can use that to exfiltrate things like CSRF tokens or user data.
And then if you do, you know, CSRF tokens, you've just got full access to CSRF, so a lot of times you can get account takeover or something like that.
So, really, really creative flow here.
Love it, Mehdi.
Congratulations on the winning of being put into the list.
I don't even know.
Is it called?
It's not called a nomination.
What is the final round candidates is the thing that they use.
Yeah, the top 10, being in the top 10, I guess.
Yeah.
Congrats for being in the top 10.
Cool.
Yeah, so number, what is this?
Number eight?
Number eight, yep.
Yeah, so number eight, man, this was an insane bug.
I was reading through this and I was like, how is this even, how is it possible that this is insane?
I know.
Frickin', I cannot believe that some, and I love how also, just before you explain this one, because you take this one, Joel.
But I just want to say, like, I love how in here, in this article, they talk about how, like, what things should have saved them.
Like, what kind of, like, weird little, like, weird math things or, like, weird checks that actually should have made it, like, you know, we see that all the time in bugs.
Like, you have this attack vector and then, like, the developer just gets lucky and, like, some weird thing doesn't work out and it breaks the whole exploit.
And he, he notes, the author here notes a couple of them.
And they just, you know, what, what, what things could have happened but actually didn't to save them and it just seems like a perfect storm for this vulnerability.
God, we've talked about this so often, but read the docs.
Yeah, man.
Read the docs.
Read how it's supposed to work and then look at how it's actually working.
For sure.
Right, because this is something that happens over and over again and we're going to see this also in some of the other bugs that we talk about in this list, but reading the docs is so huge.
Actually, the next one we talked about is going to also be a very big read the docs moment, right?
So, essentially, this bug was a lack of ECDSA signature verification in, like, Java 15, 16, 17, and 18.
Oh, my gosh.
So, yeah.
So, essentially, what happened is the Java implementation of ECDSA got rewritten from C++ into native Java.
And when that happened, the migration was missing a lot of the safety checks that should have been in the ECDSA algorithm for hashing.
And so, essentially, what happened is if you gave it a signature that's all zeros, TLDR is that the math is zero times anything is zero, right?
And so, if you multiply a blank signature that's all zeros by anything, it's always going to come back valid.
And so, I mean, it seems simple, right?
Oh, my gosh.
It hurts me.
It hurts me, man.
It really does.
It's so crazy.
And this blog does a great job of sort of walking you through without getting, like, super, super technical.
Yeah.
Because I think any time you sort of delve into, like, the crypto side, like, the elliptic curves and all that kind of stuff.
The cryptography side, to be clear.
Yes, the cryptography, not the cryptocurrency, but the cryptography side, that crypto.
Yeah.
It can, I mean, even for me, it goes way over my head a lot of the time.
Yeah, yeah.
But this was to a level that even I could understand.
Yeah.
And essentially, what happens is, like I said, if you give it a fully blank signature, if you look at the math behind the scenes, zero times anything is zero.
Dude, what is your cat doing, man?
All right, dude, I think this might be the one.
I think this is going to be the one where we're going to post a video.
So if you want to see what Joel's cat is eating out of it, I don't know, what is he even doing?
But this is the one.
Okay.
But, yeah, man, I totally agree.
I think, you know, he really talks about the basics of, you know, R and S.
And I'm, to be clear as well, I'm not big on the math side of things.
People hear, oh, you're a hacker, oh, you're computer science, you know, must be a math boy.
I'm not a math boy.
So, but, yeah, no, this stuff is simple enough and really well explained.
The perfect, the perfect example of what you want to see in a write-up, I think.
So, shout out to them.
It's the perfect storm of bad things.
And one of the awesome things that I, that I bookmarked that was mentioned, and I had never heard of this, but there's a thing called Project, I think it's Weishproof.
Oh, yeah, I saw that, yeah.
Is that how it's printed?
I'm not really sure.
W-Y-C-H-E-P-R-O-O-F.
Yeah, I have no idea.
But it's by the Google security team.
And essentially what it's designed to do is it runs crypto libraries through, like, a standard test suite.
And it'll feed, like, known crypto issues, including this bug that was talked about with a blank signature being validated incorrectly.
And it lets you sort of sanity check to make sure that everything is working right.
And Neil said that he ran it.
He, you know, updated Weishproof to work with the Java versions that he was testing against.
And sure enough, he found it immediately.
Wow.
So I think that's a really great thing if you're working at a company or maybe you're auditing something crypto-specific.
Maybe just run it through that Weishproof tool and see if it finds anything.
Because that's certainly a lot easier than doing all the auditing yourself and trying to find the nuances within the code if it'll just be like, hey, there's an issue here and here's what it is.
Wow.
Yeah, dude, that's awesome.
And I also just want to say about on the topic of Weishproof, I clicked on the GitHub repo and at the top of the GitHub repo it says, like, ah, project Weishproof is named after Mount Weishproof, the smallest mountain in the world.
And then you go here and it's like, it's got a, on Wikipedia, it's got a picture of just like a field.
It's like, this is the mountain.
Wait, okay, I'm looking at this.
Yeah, I don't even know, man.
I don't, I have no idea.
So, yeah, shout out to Google for, yeah, crazy.
It seems like 138 feet tall or 42 meters.
That's so small, dude.
That's like a tree.
I feel like I'm about to go on a rabbit hole about what makes a mountain a mountain.
Don't, don't do it, Joel.
Don't do it, man.
Don't do it.
Don't get nerd sniped by Google.
Yeah, no, I really also like, the one thing that I did want to shout out was the multiplicative inverse explanation.
Really clean, really simple.
And it shows that he really did his due diligence in diving into the code and really understanding all the pieces.
So, shout out to Neil Madden and congrats for making it into the top 10.
Yeah, that really makes me think about some other, like, migrations that are like that.
Because, I mean, this is Java.
He mentioned that this is used in JWT and a lot of other, like, very core, like, functions.
Yeah.
And it makes me wonder what other migrations have happened in other languages from either, like, C++ bindings to native language bindings or other instances of that where they may have forgotten some checks.
And there might be some other really, really critical CVs in there.
Yeah, for sure.
And I would like to, just a takeaway for the people that are listening, if you want to, or maybe I'll do this after, we'll see.
But I would love to just go ahead and generate this zero signature.
I don't, I mean, I don't know if it's actually, like, do you need, you know, 64 bytes of zero or something like that for, like, a JWT?
You know how, like, there's some weird stuff in, what's the BIRT plugin?
I want to say it's, like, Joseph or something like that, where you throw a JWT in there and then it, like, signs it with, like, you know, none or something like that.
And it's just an empty string and it modifies the first part of the JWT and stuff like that.
I do that every time I see a JWT because one time I found one and it was, like, oh, my gosh, this is nuts.
And so I would also, it would be really cool to just have, like, just be able to, like, paste a signature in there and check and see if that works and see if they're using a vulnerable version of Java.
So it would be great to, like, tweet out that, like, 64 byte, whatever it is, and do it that way.
Yeah, this is reminding me of, I've seen this in a couple of CTFs and puzzles, but essentially it'll be using the default, like, or, like, the example code as in your, like, production.
So if you're looking at, like, just the, like, the readme page and, like, how to encrypt with insert crypto library and then you copy-paste that code, typically there'll be, like, a default key or a default ID or something in there.
And if it ever gets left, then super easy win.
Or same thing with if they're using an empty key or a null key and you can replicate that and you can re-sign your own.
Yeah.
I know for JWTs, you can pretty easily check this by just going to, like, JWT.io and you can just paste your JWT in there and you can re-sign it and it'll tell you whether or not it's valid for a given signing key.
And so you can test with, like, an empty key or a known key or an example key and you can see whether or not they may have signed it using that.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was trying to remember the person who wrote this.
It was Ian Carroll.
There's actually a couple years ago, he released a tool called Cookie Monster, which helps check for, like, default keys and stuff like that for vulnerable session cookies in particular on several different frameworks.
So, you know what's weird about doing a podcast, Joel, like, you start reading all of the, you know, you've read the words you've only ever read and, you know, you think that would be gone by the time you're like, you know, 25 or something words you've only read in books.
Like, oh, I'm a wordy kid that reads books or whatever.
But, no, when you're in the tech world, there's so many different names and stuff that you've only ever read and never said out loud.
It's a gotcha, man.
It really is.
But, yeah, I'll link this in the, I'll link this in the description for, of the, of the pod.
And you guys can check out Cookie Monster by Ian Carroll.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's a great example.
I know that there was another, I think this might be what I'm thinking of, but essentially, yeah, the flat, like the default flask encryption keys.
And stuff.
Yeah.
And you see that in CTFs all the time.
Where it's like, oh, like, how would we ever get the secret value?
And then you, like, you go and you look up and sure enough, there's, you know, it's one, two, three, four, one, two, three, four, one, two, three, four, or something like that.
Yeah.
All right.
Cool.
Let's keep rolling because we're only a couple down the list.
Yeah.
We might have to split this into a double episode this week or something, but all right.
Number seven, dude, we were both really excited about this one pre-episode.
What an amazing concept this one is.
So, essentially, the TLDR on this one is, there's these things called hop by hop headers.
I had no idea that's exclusive, by the way.
I know.
And, yeah, I had read the research when it originally came out and then I was like, oh, that's so cool.
I should, you know, it went into that list of, like, you know, research that I should flesh out that I never flesh out and never came back out of there.
But, luckily, Giacopo Tediasi.
Uh-oh.
We're getting back into it.
I know, man.
I'm so sorry.
I feel so bad.
Giacopo?
Yeah.
Giacopo.
You know, I should be able to pronounce this, too, because I used to speak Italian, but now my Italian is gone.
Uh-oh.
But, yeah, it's a great write-up, and there's these things called hop by hop headers, and essentially what they allow you to do is remove specific headers at specific points in the processing of an HTTP request.
So, if you've got a reverse proxy and then another reverse proxy in an actual server, you can specify, like, okay, I need this header removed at the first, you know, proxy, or if you've just got a reverse proxy in a server as well.
So, that's a really cool concept and could potentially allow for—I would also really like to see people trying to do the same thing that James Kettle does with request smuggling in here with this header.
So, like, for example, if you go through the first proxy, and then, you know, it does not process the connection header with an extra space after the end and then the colon, but the second one does,
then you can remove headers that were added by the first proxy, and, you know, it would be crazy.
But, yeah, so happy that they actually took this research that was done years before, actually, I want to say, right?
Was it three years before?
Yeah, I believe it was three years before.
Yeah, dude, that's crazy.
Let me find it.
Yeah, Nathan Davidson.
Yeah, dude, I went back and read this one yesterday.
Definitely a good read.
Nathan Davidson does a write-up on, like, okay, this is weird.
We should start looking at this.
And he's totally right.
And then, finally, you know, these guys are able to pull it off a couple years later.
Yeah, and like we talked about in the previous book, this is a perfect example.
Just read the document, like, read the documentation and take a look at what's actually happening.
I had no idea that this was a thing.
And if you read the RFC, I mean, this is from 1997, okay?
Yeah.
This is 25 years old.
It's, you know, it's been around for quite some time.
And it literally says explicitly in here that there are, like, two categories of HTTP headers.
End-to-end headers, which are carried throughout the entire request.
And hop-by-hop headers, which are meant for transport-level connections.
And they're not stored or used after they're forwarded by a proxy or a cache.
And they say, here are the hop-by-hop headers.
And they list specifically connection, keep alive, public, proxy authenticate, transfer encoding, upgrade.
All other headers defined as by HTTP 1.1 are end-to-end headers.
Hop-by-hop headers introduced in future versions of HTTP must be listed in a connection header.
Okay.
Like, it's, like, extremely verbose.
It explains exactly how this should happen.
And you can read that and be like, huh, cool, and just keep moving.
But Jacopa did an amazing, you know, they sort of, like, turned it around.
They were like, hang on a second.
If we send two requests concatenated together, like, in request smuggling, and there's headers
that we need to remove here, I could just define it as a hop-by-hop header and put it in the
connection header in my first request, and it'll get removed.
And sure enough, exactly by the spec, it gets removed.
It's so crazy.
That's so cool.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, I totally agree.
Reading the docs, big, big dub.
And so just to TLDR, what happened here.
So they would send the request, and this request would have a content-length header of 53 in
a content body that was actually another HTTP request.
And then it would specify the connection header as the, and the content-length header inside of
the connection header as a hop-by-hop sort of header here.
Then when the first proxy was processing it, it would split the, it would pull off the content-length
header.
Then it would split the request into two different requests.
And then what would end up happening is the response to that request would get sent back
to the user, the request that was inside of the request body, that was originally a part
of the request body, gets processed and parsed as its own request and gets sent back to the
user, or actually, the proper thing to say would it gets put back into the response queue on
the Akamai proxy, and then you can trigger that by reaching out with another request.
So really awesome job here.
Essentially what they, what it allowed, you know, this, this team to do was just send that,
that request and return back just arbitrary content, which is devastating.
And this affected, I want to say, the whole Akamai CDN.
Yeah, I think it was on every edge node, which is, which is kind of just like absurd.
One of the awesome things that Jacoba did was they put this, this diagram in their blog that does a
really great job of visualizing sort of the flow of how this works, where you send your request and you
include the hop by hop header in your connection header in the first request, it hits the first
proxy, gets split into two requests handled by the second proxy, two different responses, then get sent back to the
first proxy, one goes into the queue, one goes back to the requester. And then essentially, it's just
standard HTTP request. Yeah. Yeah. Beautiful, beautiful graph. Really good job, Jacopo and team.
Um, yeah. Yeah. And the, the, the, the GIF that they put in there with the POC was just like, I, I was, I was sitting at my desk and I was just looking at that and I was like, are you serious? And I had to zoom in and I was like, no way.
Yeah. It's just like a curl request. And then they hit some other arbitrary path. And it just returns, you know, uh, robots.txt on like some hacker one underscored.js. It's like, you know, it's, it's an amazing POC. It's awesome.
Yeah, it is. Yeah. About halfway down on the page. They're just stunning. You can just upload any content you want to, you know, paypal.com demo.com was the one they're using here. Really, really awesome bug. All right, dude. It looks like we might only get through maybe the top six today. We might have to do another one later this week or cover it again next week. But let's talk about number six and then we'll, we'll sort of wrap it up.
Cool. Yeah. So, um, essentially this, this was actually researched directly from James Kettle, who works at Portswigger. Um, and this was, uh, talking about, uh, injecting a separate HTTP request, uh, and very similar to the previous bug, but with like response queuing and all that kind of stuff, the attack factor was very interesting. When I was reading through this, it took me a second to actually understand how it was going through, but essentially the whole payload goes right in your
request path. So if you think about how an HTTP request actually works, um, like when you request, you know, example.com slash foobar, right. It's going to go make an HTTP request. That's get space slash foobar space HTTP slash 1.1, et cetera. And the whole payload, you would URL encode, you know, new lines slash r slash n or percent zero D percent zero A. And then you put host headers and all that kind of stuff. And it would get,
decoded URL decoded. And basically the full raw request within two full requests in there. So James explained that somebody had reached out to him and was like, Hey, I have this weird bug. I don't really know how to exploit this. Do you have any ideas? And he mentioned, generally speaking, these are types of things that you don't really respond to. Cause most of the time it's just that you've hit a wall. Like you can't actually exploit it. But he had done some previous research, um, that he had published that was talking about the same exact type of thing. And he was like, you know, this feels
this feels like something that might actually be exploitable let me let me take a closer look
and sure enough you literally just you put the whole you put the whole request in there just
literally like zero zero a and it just turns it into two requests and you have almost like exact
like standard http request smuggling and he did uh he did talk about some of the nuances which is
really nice about um some of the more modern preventions that are coming into play around this
yeah um where like a lot of times browsers if it receives two content lengths it'll stop uh it'll
truncate the data that it receives uh early because the content length is not short enough
um but there are still like other ways that you can get around that you can you know either you can
give it a longer content length you can fiddle with it or you can get it to maybe um you can get
it to be in the in the response queue instead so you get a full response back um but uh yeah no this
is an awesome bug from james james has just like he's whenever i think of request smuggling he kills
it man he kills it he's done so much unique and original research on request smuggling that's all
like published and he's given like so many talks and stuff um yeah it's uh every time i see another
post about i'm like dang how much further can we go with request smuggling and it seems like there's
no end yeah and seriously and i i think i think uh i think in one of the descriptions of the uh
write-ups in on the top 10 web hacking techniques i think he quote yeah here it is as noted by file
descriptor it seems like there's an infinite amount of anomalies among proxies that bring you an infinite
amount of request smuggling techniques very well said totally agree um once again another banger by
by james um yeah i i really like this and i've always i've always thought um and well actually
let me let me say this first it makes me think of another article that i read um in 2020 by franz
um uh regarding nginx misconfigurations so i'm gonna link that below we don't have time to go into the
details of it now but um really awesome read uh you know franz is number one on this uh top web
hacking techniques list so you'll definitely hear more from him but pretty much anything that's published
on detectify from franz is like straight gold so definitely check those out yeah i feel like franz is
getting to the level where like anytime you see like a new project zero blog post you're like uh-oh
this is probably bad and same thing if i see a new franz like detectify blog post uh-oh yeah no for
sure man and i was catching up with him you know uh what event was that at he was at one of the events
that i was at recently and i was catching up with him and he like runs a couple companies too and like
does all this like i'm just like who are you like how do you do this yeah yeah family yeah it's
amazing so yeah really cool stuff goals there um let's see yeah no i don't think i have any other
comments on this one this one's pretty pretty cool how they just wrote out the whole htp request i think
you did a great job explaining it so i guess we'll leave it there um let's see what time are we at
we're at 49 minutes right now um yeah all right i'll talk real quickly i'm not going to get to talk
about that bug that i was going to talk about uh joel but we'll we'll actually i'll give you guys
i'll i'll do the css bug that i was talking about next time um and we'll you know we'll spend some
decent amount of time there i did want to um shoot out a couple tips here at the end um one
and you'll see this when we get to number one on the list uh but franz's post message tracker
extension is a necessity that is absolutely something everyone should have installed
go download that and keep your you know inspect your dev tools tab open to see what kind of post
messages are being sent because there's a lot of scope there and it's it's pretty much like an api
for the browser that you can access cross origin um depending on how it's set up so it's it's really
it's definitely something that should be paid attention to it's it's pretty awesome i forgot that
this was actually a public tool because franz gave me a private copy of it yeah years ago and uh and i
was using that for a while and then eventually he finally released it and but for those who aren't
familiar it's essentially it's a browser plugin that will log all of the data that's going um in post
message calls so between like windows or between tabs um via you know window.post message um and it's
really really insightful because that's an awesome vector for like xss csrf there's like a million
different things that you can do and you can see all the different data that's being triggered
between the two events whether or not there's an origin check all that kind of stuff so
there there's a lot of really really juicy stuff to be had and uh yeah that tool is free and
available so go get it yeah i'm gonna go ahead and just add these right right now to the show
put it in our link actually i also did a little bit of a write-up on post message stuff where i mentioned
his uh his tracker extension and a little bit more detail so i'm going to link that below as well
i actually think it's really good at the pace we're going to because uh we've basically gotten through
uh number 10 through four it through the five or four yeah and uh i think what what we might do is
we'll leave the last the top three for the listener so if you're interested and you've liked what you've
heard so far i mean the top three are like even better right it's like so freaking good it's like
and number one like i said number one is a franz rosenberg it's an amazing write-up um there's just
like so many awesome techniques and takeaways that you can get from all of these so i would encourage
you to just go back even if you've listened to us talk about these go back and read them yourself
um the write-ups we're we're really only like skimming over them i don't think we can oh yeah
full justice not even close every single write-up and so definitely takes take some time make some
notes i feel like i have like an endless list of like new things that i need to be checking for now
whatever i'm hacking on targets um and especially around request smuggling uh it's just like man
there's so there's so much unexplored attack service yeah for sure man um all right that's a
wrap i don't think i've got anything else in the tip section um we always appreciate you i mean you
could see at the beginning of the episode how excited we were about those reviews um and uh you know
ratings on apple podcasts and on spotify and wherever you listen so definitely do us a solid and leave
us some reviews and uh yeah we'll we'll talk to you next week on the pod oh i actually do have one
one quick tip oh and this is something that i i told you wow joel coming out here with a with a tip
i saved it it's not even in the doc joel i know it's written on a sticky note on my desk so um
freaking joel man yeah peak adhd yeah so i i had told you about this after our episode yesterday but i
wanted to to pass it on to the to the community um one of our hacking buddies uh had mentioned that they
got an akamai ban and we talked a little bit about yeah yeah these bugs but if you ever come
across an akamai ban you've been a little too aggressive on your scanning your payloads or whatever
we've all been there i definitely was not banned from usps for like three weeks oh my gosh
but um but yeah if you ever come across an akamai ban uh one you can go to akamai site and you can
check and there's like a button that you can click that will tell you the reputation for your current
ip sort of tell you whether or not you've been flagged and whether why you've been flagged and
whether or not you know you can access akamai websites uh but if you want to get around that
immediately you can change the mac address on your router so most routers i think probably
i don't think i've ever seen a router that doesn't let you do it but generally speaking you can go in
and you can change the mac address for your router itself and it's essentially the same as changing a
mac address on like your laptop right you're the the router no longer identifies the same client so it
gives you a new ip address same thing with your isp your isp no longer recognizes your router
gives you no ip so you can just trick dhcp into giving you a new public ip address by just changing
your router mac by like one character and then you can just leave it like that for a couple weeks
set a reminder change it back and you'll be good to go on that same page that i mentioned that akamai
you can look up your ip reputation there's also like an appeal button or something and i'd also
recommend just hit that say i'm you know i'm a security researcher i was authorized to do the
scanning um and you know if you you can't wait just change your mac by a little bit and you'll get
a new public ip nice pro tips man pro tips that those bands are so annoying and and i'm gonna just
i'm gonna keep rolling man i got another tip that popped into my brain joel joel uh joel style um
on this note of changing the mac um i think this is a pretty classic tip but for most web people i'm
not sure it's it's super intuitive but i was um i was doing a physical uh test one time and i got on
a network and i plugged up an ethernet cable to my laptop and it wouldn't give me an ip address and i
was like oh what's going on well the device that i had unplugged i plugged that into my laptop and i
opened up wireshark and i grabbed the mac address for that um for that specific device and i spooked
my mac address to that mac address and then i plugged back up to the network and i got an ip
so um it's a it's you know just a little little little tip here and there um and you know maybe
you'll use that in your in your next uh physical stuff that you do so yeah yeah you never know when
that's going to come in handy sweet cool that it that's it for me all right sweet that's the pod
see you guys next week awesome take care
i definitely just left it and didn't end the recording dude i was just sitting in here